okay thank you very much it was a
passion project spearheaded by two
former alberta politicians with deep
personal ties to ukraine
former premier ed stalmak who is of
ukrainian descent and former deputy
premier thomas lukaszek who came to
canada as a polish refugee i remember
waking up with tanks and cannons and
armored vehicles in front of our
apartment in the academia poland
complements of the soviet union
within weeks of russia's invasion and
with the support of people from across
western canada the group collected and
shipped more than 300 tons of much
needed aid the medical supplies search
and rescue equipment and personal care
items filled two warehouses before it
was sent to the region by both air and
sea most of our items end up somewhere
in poland and then delivered in minivans
and passenger vehicles
to specific locations to hospitals
medical clinics to shelters orphanages
but the journeys to those towns and
cities hardest hit in the eastern part
of ukraine can be perilous and on
saturday lou kazakh was forced to
deliver tragic news a couple days ago we
lost a couple of drivers
one
polish one ukrainian national there were
three one manage thankfully to escape i
can't share
the exact circumstances but they were
intercepted two were killed
paul hughes knows this risk first hand
the former canadian soldier from calgary
has been in ukraine since march
completing 50 aid delivery missions
across the country so far predominantly
medical aid and food
and shelter related supplies some of
these missions are three-day missions
like it's
it's uh the road system here is
very challenging
despite the danger lukaszic says most of
the aid collected in alberta has been
able to get to those in need thanks to
the heroism of these drivers and there's
no other way to describe it
but more than two months into fighting
the calls for help are only growing
louder the kha'zix team is now focusing
on raising money to purchase food and
medical aid while paul hughes is
prepared to keep making deliveries for
up to another year
heather urex west global news calgary